this clip was going around over the
weekend
this is that guy joe scarborough who
used to be kind of saying he went off
the deep end he married his co-host
misha brzezinski and she's sort of nuts
too and i want you to listen to this
this is in 2017
when they're talking about donald trump
and how they're losing the narrative and
this guy basically might start doing
things that they don't like but i want
you to listen to this and think about it
as if it was yesterday and then talking
about a lot elon musk and i think you're
going to see sort of how this thing
operates so again just to be clear this
is 2017 talking about trump but tell me
how different this is then exactly what
the machine wants you to think about
elon musk today who were trump voters
and are still trump supporters they go
yeah you guys are going crazy
he's doing what are you so surprised
about he's doing exactly what he said
he's going to do well and i think that
the dangerous you know edges here are
that he's trying to undermine the media
trying to make up his own facts and it
could be that while unemployment and uh
the economy worsens he could have
undermined the messaging so much that he
can actually
control
exactly what people think and that is
the that is our job yeah if you look at
the issues uh
yamiche is right he's doing exactly what
he said
did you catch that part please later
rewind it and watch it again he can
actually control
uh exactly what people think and that is
the that is our job it's her job to tell
you what's true people it's her job
it can't be somebody else's job it's
their job over at msnbc to tell you what
is true but you see it's the same thing
evil donald trump was undermining the
media elon musk is undermining the media
undermining corporate press undermining
the messaging
scary people undermining the messaging
letting more people talk giving you the
tools and opportunity to fight for
yourself crazy orange man and
rich billionaire with his spaceships but
there's more from
msnbc uh here's katie turner who's a
msnbc hosted she's freaking out she's
freaking
there are real
and devastating consequences for using
that platform to lie and we've seen it
we've seen it happen
i i wonder
you know when talking about this it's
you know it's kind of funny elon musk's
want wants to buy it but there are
massive
life and globe alter altering
consequences for just letting people run
wild on the thing
yes
she's basically crying saying that more
people might be able to say things what
is she talking about people lie on
twitter every day people lie in real
life every day open up facebook it is a
litany of lies you people are the chief
architects of all of the lies you're not
against lies you're against other people
telling the truth is what you're
actually trying to say these hysterical
children should all be studied and
institutionalized